i got a movie called splash city all
about the the bibing in the bay area i
really want to bring to life like
northern california crime stories and
like just northern california is on tap
like if you really look at a lot of
crime films or movies in general based
on l.a well especially
on a commercial worldwide level yeah
there's nothing
out the bank i feel like that's my job
right so
my hobby now is just developing content
uh barrier-based like and it's [ __ ] up
it's not really a hobby i guess it's
like work but
that's what i like to do now that i'm
working with empire i go to san
francisco often at least once a month
i'm there
and you know i'll talk to guys like uh
like amen or you know shabazz like guys
from the bay and they're like yo the
energy's kind of out of the city right
now it is
like what like what do you think kind of
the bae is right now because
i'll go there and i'll be like man i
remember when i was coming here five or
six years ago like there was like a
it feels like the vibe is kind of
missing right now
the bay area is a tough place
that's the best way i could describe it
it's just tough every aspect of life
just tough
it's expensive
it's expensive
a lot of not a lot of people made it
from the bay people don't trust each
other there's no unity like it's just
weird yeah it feels like a very like uh
especially now too like
you can't even go to a [ __ ]
restaurant if you're not vaccinated it's
just you can't even go to a restaurant
without getting your windows broken
either so it's like you know oh yeah
because it's the smash and grab capital
that's why i'm doing the movies splash
city it's crazy
new school ninja as you drive baby is
that what the movie's kind of yeah it's
all based on that
yeah because for people who don't know
san francisco's the smash and grab
capital of the world
it's crazy your window gets smashed out
if you got anything in your [ __ ] car
and if you don't there's some popping
windows they're just going to see what's
in there yeah that [ __ ] is wild man